taking out the police taking out ice
taking out the borders
inflation up gas prices up boy
if these people if the goal is to
destroy everything they're doing a hell
of a job about it right they're doing a
heck of a job and here's the key video
now that i want you to see here because
they're doing it intentionally and there
simply is no doubt about it here is a
compilation of democrats talking about
why
they're doing all of this
and uh you know how you are just gonna
have to suck it up you peon the future
of transportation is electric gas prices
have hit a new record high in america
and expected to keep rising you need to
make sure that it becomes relatively
more attractive to have an electric
vehicle instead of a gas you want gas
prices to go up in oil prices you need
it to reflect the true cost of carbon
number one no more subsidies for fossil
fuel industry no more drilling on
federal lands no more drilling including
offshore no ability for the oil industry
to continue to drill period ends record
high gas prices the national average now
at four dollars and 29 cents a gallon a
60 cent hike in just one week the
president is really focused on making
sure that people are not heard of the
pump several around la that are more
than six bucks a gallon if you drive an
electric car this would not be affecting
you clearly there's no sound or fuel how
many barrels of oil does the us consume
per day i don't have that number in
front of me how do i know it's actually
working what is the grand home plan to
increase oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious perhaps if you let the
market work in this respect people will
feel pain they'll take a second look at
that ford f-450 gigantoid truck they'll
reconsider a tesla i'm willing to pay
four dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla i have
a chevy bolt that is my car i lease a
bolt and i lease
solar panels so i
drive on sunshine girl
these people are all better than you
guys
they have more than you and they want
you to know that now
i want to admit something here i just
got a new tesla last week i did
i work very hard i have a couple
successful businesses
i lease the tesla which actually is
probably not the best idea because
tesla's because of all of this will
retain their value over the years um i'm
not against electric cars the tesla is
one of the coolest
uh innovations that we've had in america
worldwide actually in the last 20 years
it really is it's really like driving a
different thing than driving a regular
car like it's all
digital to drive to go forward you have
to slide your finger up to go backwards
you have to slide everything down like
it's just super cool the automated
driving all of the stuff okay so i'm not
sitting here telling you that electric
is bad it's not and if we could figure
out a way to to convert to more
renewable energy
safely and securely and also not destroy
the economy at the exact same time and
if any of this would have any real
effect on the environment which is a
whole separate topic knowing that we can
only control what we do within our
borders but other countries going
through their own industrial revolutions
china india for example huge massive
countries doing whatever they want if
they're going to keep doing all of that
stuff and we're just going to harm our
economy in the name of green energy
we're going to be worse off the simple
truth is that fossil fuels
and gas and fracking and all of these
things and especially nuclear
these are the things that are still the
best way to raise more people up out of
poverty they are trying to destroy the
whole damn thing they really are here is
video of secretary of energy
jennifer granholm she was in the little
compilation we just showed you there
talking about how we can't let this
ukrainian moment go to waste because
there's something else going on here
maybe it's something to do with a new
world order as you can imagine and as
you have heard there is a lot of
conversation that is happening right now
in in saying that this crisis
in uh in europe and the crisis our
allies are facing and the reduction of
supply of
natural gas and oil from russia
creates a moment that we should be
acting
i mean we heard president zielinski we
do not want to see uh any country that
is held hostage to vladimir putin and
this is a moment for congress to be able
to act
there can be a compromise there can be
movement on this
um and whether it's you know i mean what
the form is and
sponsors are and all of that that's uh
that's a conversation that's happening
but the bottom line is
this is a moment to have this happen
it's an urgent moment
what this is what a crazy coincidence
guys i actually can't believe this these
people who all want us to move off of
energy the way we've done it for so long
and we can again have that conversation
about how we can clean up some things
related to all of that and how you
actually transition without destroying
an economy
they suddenly got this war out of
nowhere that no one's exactly sure
what's going on there and it's the
perfect moment for them to usher in the
thing that they want to usher in these
guys they're the luckiest people on
earth jennifer granholm
and joe biden are lucky they're just so
lucky and gay pete and all of them
they're just so lucky that we got this
war so they could do their energy thing
it's just great